[Music]
i was very close to the brothers
and able to observe was they were very
tense as they walked into that chapel
as they came out of it you could see
some of that
tension diffuse duchess kate appeared to
be the peacemaker between the two
brothers as they emerged from st
george's chapel following the emotional
service you know she loved harry
he said she is the sister that he never
had she's been heartbroken
to see them fall out i certainly think
she's played quite an important role
in getting the brothers to the point
where they were able to engage in a
conversation of course
in front of the world's press a lip
reader analyzed the brothers chat
and deciphered william saying absolutely
beautiful service
harry's supposed response it was as he
wanted it
it was certainly the storing of the ice
the queen poignantly sat alone during
the less than one hour service
her final farewell a handwritten note
she placed on the top of philip's casket
and signed lilly bett her childhood
nickname
he is probably the last person to have
called her lily bet
and i think there will be great
poignancy in that that
she will never be called anywhere again
now the big question is
when will harry return to the u.s the
queen will turn 95 on wednesday
i'm sure he'd love to be here for her
birthday but i think there's also a part
of him that is
understandably keen to get back to his
heavily pregnant wife
and his little boy now because the queen
is in mourning there won't be a big
celebration for her birthday